there's a bit of a Charlie's Angels vibe in
the sense of you got these three women and
then you got Nick Fury who's like a Bosley
what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we got ourselves a trailer representing
us three men the Marvels today joined of course
with John John good morning how's your six
in the morning going that's so good I'm ready
for everyone to agree with my opinion today
John is not here you're a koi koi last name
yes yes I tried making it work how are you
going it's early I am well and I'm ready to
fight the internet we do not acknowledge them
but you know who them are I like to acknowledge
them so are we acknowledging that I think
we're just saying them but we're not specifying
them but you're filling in the blanket it's
a mad libs intro today please go ahead leave
a like that would mean the world tell us your
thoughts down below what you thought of this
trailer oh boy and also you just invited The
Piano Guys the threshold oh and also uh today's
video is indeed sponsored by G fuel gonna
talk more about them after the trailer reaction
specifically because I wanted to give a very
personal shout out to how they have really
helped change my lifestyle I've seen a good
amount of you guys commenting the comment
boxes about how oh girl you look like you're
getting in better shape well you know what
do you feel has been a big part of that change
for me no just an overall lifestyle change
for me as well so yeah more on them after
the reaction let's get into it people
Captain Rambo what the hell are you doing
Sabers during the jump Point perimeter I'm
gonna get you some readings Fury hello [Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
she got villani too whoa
where's Captain Rambo [Music] whoa uh the
Miss Marvel postcard I think it's the first
time with post credits but in the trailer
what universe is this is this 606 is it nine
nine nine nine we're looking I can't wait
to see
okay so our powers all right angles energy
and you I could totally show you oh my oh
[__] wow hi where's our daughter wherever
you are oh no forking hey
[Laughter]
it's a galactic Planet planetary intergalactic
the planet the musical Planet yeah there's
multiples working wow there must be there's
a whole race of them yeah that fight we're
not a team you're a superhero pose on why
are they fighting each other there awesome
awesome sauce girls get it done well that
looked like a lot of fun all right well we're
gonna go through this trailer frame by frame
in just a second but overall yeah it looks
like it's actually look looks genuinely fun
if that makes sense you know not like the
safe word fun it looks like oh it seems like
everyone on screen is having like a really
good time and I'm most excited for Iman villani
a really quick job what you think I'm excited
as well this I mean the trio of them is the
heart and soul of you know what makes this
look so funny Iman villani is a treasure and
I think leading with fun after the response
to the first movie is a good direction to
head in for this to build good yeah I think
it's the first time we've seen a post-credits
scene from a show in a trailer so I think
it's really smart to show that connection
if you didn't watch the show if you've just
been at the movies but it's also I think the
tone is really smart especially after they've
moved the movie to November I think it's smart
to show confidence like this is a big Sci-Fi
Action comedy have a bold fun funny trailer
as opposed to like just a teaser I think with
smart out of the gates wrong the implications
do seem like they could factor into the bigger
part of the Multiverse Saga like I feel like
this could lead to some incursion events at
the same time it does feel like it's really
focused on the immediate plot and not just
setting up the future but guys before that
I do want to play my my little special solo
ad thank you to G fuel for sponsoring this
video now guys G fuel is by far the easiest
thing for me to shout out on this channel
reason why is because g-fuel plain and simple
no if Sans or buts it has been a part of my
lifestyle for several months now you guys
might have noticed you might see me drinking
G fuel quite a lot on this channel on videos
that are not sponsored by G fuel it's just
my main choice of Beverage to help keep me
hydrated or help keep me awake and alert now
I really love the the very fortunate very
blessed position that we're in that we get
to make a living doing something as weird
as this however sometimes there could be a
lot of very early mornings and sometimes obnoxious
late nights sometimes there's all Niners that
are being pulled to give you an idea last
week with everything that was coming out everything
I had to prep for YouTube and page patreon
I was averaging like two to four hours of
sleep at night now the reason I'm bringing
that up is because when Greg is tired on camera
I know those comments Greg looks sad Greg
looks depressed Greg looks bored with the
channel he's over it when really a lot of
times I'm just tired and I just might not
be as expressive in that moment that's why
having a beverage like G fuel I really love
because it helps keep me focused helps keep
me alert helps keep me awake and best part
is it doesn't give me like some spiked up
Pulse or even lead to some gnarly crash ever
the other thing I want to talk about too is
a lot of you guys have been so kind as to
point out and Yeah it feels like a weirdly
self-conscious talking about it but a lot
of you guys have pointed out that hey look
like you're getting better shape crack and
I have half a month and a half and I've been
taking dieting and exercise a little bit more
serious again so thank you to all those super
kind comments I've seen coming in and a big
part of my fitness regime is implementing
g-fuel into my life like I enjoy getting the
can out of the fridge there's a nice convenience
to that when filming on camera or giving it
to a one of the many people who come on this
channel but the reason I've been clutching
onto this blender bottle is because when it
comes to working out I prefer for the powder
they got a lot of different flavors and I
just use one scoop of G fuel now they're not
advertised as a pre-workout but I personally
use it as my pre-worked out if I'm out of
cans like I currently am right now I can just
make some powder in the water get the same
exact flavor and effect sometimes if I'm not
planning on working out but I still want to
you know have a good wake me up I will just
mix some g-fuel into like a a morning shake
or something like that also after I worked
out and especially on days that I do cardio
like today I use their hydration powder which
I can either take on its own or I can mix
it in with some after workout shake so yeah
guys if you are interested you can use our
promo code in the description box and pin
comment reject Nation for 20 off select tubs
and on top of that too it is a great way to
support the channel I said this to my G fuel
rep many times I love to be partnered with
them forever however even if a partnership
happened to fall through happens sometimes
I would still be a loyal customer plain and
simple so thank you g fuel again back to the
video okay so at the very beginning of this
trailer saying saber space station not sword
not Shield saber what is saber koi I'm gonna
own something went to Google it and I feel
better because it didn't immediately pop up
because I was like do I just not know an entire
organization the internet's with me and I'll
just own that embarrassing moment live uh
yeah I'm assuming it's Shield uh you know
is the S and then maybe it's it's new to the
MCU or it is like a more obscure space designation
I don't know and doesn't immediately come
up on Google but I didn't know this right
away I'll own that and it looks like this
is probably the space station where Nick Fury
has been camping I know with the Scrolls am
I right about this yeah did they saber at
the end of the Nick Fury commentary I don't
remember that name ever popping up I'm wondering
how this is going to factor into secret invasion
is this like revealing that Nick Fury survives
secret Invasion even though the trailer is
saying will Nick Fury die in the events of
secret information
unless he's never on earth and the skrull
in secret Invasion dies that we think is him
because he's clearly in space so here we go
Star Trek and no it does look very Star Trek
yeah all on that oh yeah do you have any idea
who these people are koi vague henchmen in
space no you're supposed to know everything
well this blue guy is clearly commissary 67
from Avengers
well
yeah I do like the way this set looks because
this looks like a studio set and I think that's
very purposeful I feel like this set is supposed
to look like a Star Trek 60 set like supposed
to look a little cheap well the most part
it feels like that doesn't look like Kubrick's
move Landing fake but the movie feels like
it's supposed to be very stylized and that
seems intentional if you've seen Candyman
yet acosta's film like the way it's shot at
all of her choices are very visually aesthetic
and you can even see that in the mom mondalani
shot when she's pivoting around do you have
a practical camera turn into Nick Fury like
a lot of that spiral imagery reminds me of
her directing style so I'd say this aesthetic
is all very intentional Victoria Alonso directs
the movies not whoever's not hot this time
around I'll admit when this moment came up
on screen too of seeing Kamala Khan family
that got me really excited because they were
there I mean yes Monica Rambo also introduced
via television show but we spent so much time
with the Khan family in in the Miss Marvel
series that it was really exciting like oh
my God they're the puck from the tell that
from the television Vibe into the big screen
live action to crossing over with this gave
me that crossover event excitement in a weirder
way because it's not as obvious or as apparent
as like Avengers crossing over as soon like
the con families that's pretty cool yeah red
dagger looks like is that him in the bottom
left there I don't think so I think that's
just some guy there's not just gonna be a
guy at dinner why is he got a thing oh he's
tied up here he was blurry that's not really
a bad guy it seemed oh this must have happened
when the switcheroo already occurred yeah
to fight whoever came over here yeah because
remember red dagger had the finger on his
face yeah uh but this is not him I do like
the cinematography a lot more looking at these
visuals because there's something more striking
about it it doesn't look like overly blown
out or like inexpensive really bright yeah
yeah but it still maintains a certain kind
of colorfulness that I feel like they get
dogged for not having so I'm hoping that maybe
this is a more vibrant looking movie and totally
Miss Marvel is a very vibrant character in
the comics and in her show and it's good to
see Captain Marvel get to play in that because
I think that suits Brie Larson's take more
I wonder will this be the first time the um
Monica Rambo and Carol Danville are reuniting
in this scene right here ah that'd be interesting
could be a big old family love the new suit
for Captain Marvel by the way I know looks
great looks fantastic there's a bit of a Charlie's
Angels vibe in this sense of you got these
three women and then you got Nick Fury who's
like a Bosley
the next mission is off Planet that's what
life I'm getting at least yeah no totally
I'm sure that's that was one of the touchstones
for this and it certainly seems like they're
reaching back yeah into like Kick-Ass uh girl
team you know properties as well as just maybe
even like old TV and things like that there
is like a spunky kind of older quality and
tone to this also Nick Fury's relationship
to Captain Marvel she's a captain Tiana Paris
is playing a she's at least a lieutenant right
Monica Rambo and then you've got a literal
child in a monthly so it's gonna be fun to
see those different hierarchies this thing
when they're all switch every time they use
their what the Bengal they just start uh love
the return of the floor again yes give me
a toy
this doesn't really tell you what the exact
plot of the movie is like it's telling you
the circumstances of what's going on with
our Trio here as you go a little bit further
into the trailer which does seem to have like
a bit of a mix of a typical Marvel film at
a Guardians of the Galaxy repair which is
not your typical Marvel film um but as you
go further into it I am wondering if some
of this will be dealing with the repercussions
of the events of Captain Marvel one with defeating
what what what is her name not not sorcerer
supreme Supreme sovereignty Supreme whatever
what is the freaking name
um oh I was like this person Sovereign
that it has to be dealing with the events
of Captain Marvel one I think it's gonna be
a a mix of what Captain Marvel 1 landed at
but mainly to me secret Invasion I think something
happens in secret Invasion maybe it's the
crew scroll war is started maybe something
happens why are they off Planet why are they
traveling what do they have to find or do
I'm not saying it's necessarily Creek or scroll
but something happens in secret Invasion I
think that launches this it's kind of cool
to see that secret invasion is a sequel to
Captain Marvel for Nick Fury and this is a
sequel to Captain Marvel for Carol Danvers
yeah and we haven't seen her since One Division
we haven't seen Monica Rambo so it's also
tying into where she's been because time must
have passed yeah this looks like if James
Gunn did a Bollywood dance number yes which
is exactly what a pretty large set of her
comfort zone and then into That Bouncy Carol
Danvers that everyone's hoping to find so
timing wise you got guardians in May you've
got secret invasion in June you've got this
in November I think it's a good thing to tie
that guardian's flavor into the cosmic universe
and forward I don't know who these people
are a lot of cats there are looks of it that
remind me of like Thor Ragnarok this is when
though that's what I was thinking very Ragnarok
to me this is when the lighting starts to
look like yeah a Marvel movie oh this person
this is I think the main bad guy I don't know
the main bad guy's name she's got um yeah
she's gonna accuse people so yeah it is decree
yeah that makes sense they're blue yeah yeah
so that guy looks just like Ronan right behind
her oh yeah also that yeah I think secret
invasion is definitely and I think that is
a Cree scroll War moment because that is definitely
a Cree is this Ronin no it looks like just
another guy who's a priestess yeah okay so
the henchmen that we're attacking um Monica
earlier were Cree at least at least that one
guy in the front you could judge me for not
no one from Avengers 67 they've got different
complexions some of them are blue some of
them are are human toned and why are they
fighting each other that is the question I'm
really curious about like what causes that
it's also they're not changing Powers there
so this must be like in the third act maybe
they've solved it she also has her own the
accuser staff at one point here so it makes
me think that maybe there's a possession maybe
something happens where see like that's definitely
right is that the staff I mean yeah it looks
like it the only way to make her likeable
to everyone was to make her evil all right
guys that was a fun trailer I enjoyed it I
hope that this is good likewise what did you
all think I give this trailer and an 8.5 out
of 10. I'm right there with you I was going
to say 0.7 I'm wondering I'm wondering if
we're Polaris because of the saber thing that
I can't figure out that's gonna vex me until
I get on my phone and look at all the saber
things in Marvel I give it a 7.98 oh it's
pretty good sexist oh it's a pretty good trailer
but you know there could be even more things
to discover that'll excite me that much further
I'll just give room for improvement man I
wish we had another 30 seconds so it's a full
tree
all righty guys well thank you so much for
being here thinking to G Phil for sponsoring
we'll catch y'all soon [Music]